ALISON EYRING: My story began
on the 14th of May in 2002.
It was exactly 4:50
in the afternoon
and I was working in Shanghai.
I was there with two
of my colleagues.
We were working with a client.
The day was about to end.
One of my colleagues
came up to me
with a phone in her hand,
which seemed [INAUDIBLE].
She said Alison, your family
is trying to reach you.
Immediately, my heart went here.
Because you always know
that's not a good thing.
I went outside and
I held the phone
tightly to my ear to
hear my husband's voice.
He said to me the thing that
I hope you'll never hear.
He said, Alison,
your mom and dad
have been in a car accident,
neither who survived.
That turned my life upside down.
The next 36 hours, I
can hardly remember.
I flew from Shanghai
back to Singapore.
I went to the United States.
I met my siblings.
And I was there for
three weeks with them
before I came back
home to Singapore.
When I came back to Singapore,
I was so jet lagged, as you are.
And every morning, I'd wake
up when it was still dark
and I'd crawl out of bed
and I'd go for a walk.
I called those my morning
walks because all I could do
was grieve.
Fortunately it was dark
and people passing me
couldn't see me cry.
I cried every morning but
I started walking further.
My walks, they became jogs.
My jogs became trots.
And then the trotting
became running.
And I continued to run
until December of that year.
Now, when December came, I had
a whole new wave of sadness
happen because Christmas
day was my birthday
and it was my dad's birthday.
And so growing up was always so
special because we could always
celebrate that day together.
And I knew that
day, we would never
be able to spend again
celebrating our birthdays.
So I'm really not a
cry baby, even though I
had been crying ever since May.
And I said, that's it.
I got to do something that's
going to give me some hope.
I had to do something
that's going
to make me work for the future.
So I thought really long and
hard, what would that be?
And I thought, I'll run
a marathon, as you do.
And so I did.
For the next year, I ran
and I trained and I sweat.
And I ran up till
December when many of you
may have participated in
the Stan Chart Marathon
in Singapore, of course.
A December marathon
isn't cool by any stretch
of the imagination.
And I can still
remember that day.
It was so hot I was sweating
before I even started.
And we had a start off time
at 4:00 in the morning.
I dragged myself through the
42 kilometers of that race.
And I got to the
end and I cried.
But this time, it was the worst
because it wasn't tears of joy,
but realizing that all my
running was never going
to bring my mom and dad back.
So over the last 15 years, I've
become an endurance athlete.
I realized that when I came
to the end of the marathon,
I came to the
realization that I didn't
need to run any more to
heal my broken heart.
I just loved to run and
I wanted to keep running.
So for the last 15 years,
that's what I've done.
I became an endurance athlete.
I've had a great time.
I've run, swum-- you
can say swum, I think--
and ridden a bike
thousands of kilometers.
And I've trained
for and competed
in a 100-kilometer race.
I've done a couple of half
Ironmen, a bunch of marathons,
half marathons.
I just loved it.
And I learned so much
from that experience.
I've learned so much about,
what is my maximum capacity
and what are the
capabilities that I
need to develop for a race?
I've learned a lot about
the importance of pace
and about recovery.
But most of all, I've learned
an important thing, which
is that if I want to improve
my endurance capacity,
I have to push myself to go
as fast and far as I can,
but no more until I have
the capacity to sustain it.
And that idea is so important.
That's what I call
intelligent restraint.
Now, I think it's so important.
I'm going to see if I can work
the technology and show you.
Those are the pictures
of me doing those sports.
Here's the definition.
Intelligent restraint
is a growth philosophy.
It's one that says that we
want to go as fast and far
as we can, but no more until
we have the capacity to do so.
Now, fortunately
for my family, I
am not a professional athlete.
Because if I were, it would not
help us put food on the table.
What I've been doing--
I actually have had a day
job for the last 25 years
working with
companies to help them
solve the people
and organization
challenges of growth.
And what I see is
that many of us--
and I say us because I
also lead an organization--
we don't find the right pace.
We don't quite get it right.
And when we experience that,
there's a range of things
that we experience.
One of them is that we
might see a stall in growth
or we might see
waves of what I call
boom-splat cycles of growth.
Then we might see a flurry
of activities because when
we're on the upside--
I always say growth ignores
a multitude of sins.
So then we're on a
downside, suddenly
we're busy cutting costs.
Or we're running to roll out
initiatives to stimulate sales,
but we're poorly executing.
We're inconsistently executing.
Sometimes, with
all those things,
we see employees that are
disengaged and burned out.
Now, I want to make this
more practical for you.
And I just want to
ask, could everybody
just show me your smartphone?
Does everybody have one today?
I'm not disappointed.
Now I'm, of course, feeling
a little bit exposed here
because I'm the only
one that doesn't
have a smartphone with me.
You can take your pictures now.
How many of you have a Samsung?
Some of you.
Let me talk a little
bit about the Samsung.
Now, I got to tell you, when the
Galaxy S7 was coming out-- now,
I'm pretty faithful
to my smartphone
and I like it an awful lot.
But I was tempted because
it was a good looking phone.
It was nice looking and it
was packed with features.
And the price was right.
Samsung had worked very hard.
As a company, it had become
very fast and very progressive
and quite innovative
in its space.
And when it released
the Galaxy S7,
it did a classic speedy thing
as it looked over its shoulder
at Apple in a race out.
It went too fast.
And early on, they knew
there was a problem.
But they were so fast.
They were so unwilling to
stop and to think and learn
what was going on, that they
failed to understand that they
had created a phone
that they didn't take
into account the requirements
of the battery to not catch on
fire.
Going too fast cost them
billions of dollars.
It cost a withdrawal of
a product and huge costs
associated with the brand.
And Samsung's not alone.
But let's explore another
organization, one I love.
I grew up--
Kodak was the king
of photography.
Kodak was this great company.
We all knew what a
Kodak moment was.
Does anybody else
remember a Kodak moment?
Yeah.
OK.
This is my age group here.
I'm liking it.
Kodak was amazingly innovative.
They developed the
digital camera in 1975.
But they put it
aside because they
thought it would threaten
their film business.
They weren't willing to take
that step, even when they
saw the market changing.
Even when they saw that
photography was changing,
they were unwilling to do what
they thought would threaten
their core business.
Kodak was encumbered.
It was constrained
by its success.
It had been so
successful that it
was unwilling to push hard
enough and fast enough
and it became irrelevant.
Eventually, it
declared bankruptcy.
It sold off most of its assets.
I am happy to say it is
coming back in a smaller form.
It's very focused.
But that'll be another story.
Now, it turns out that
in endurance training,
we have a lot of really
lovely rules of restraint
that can help us.
And I've always found them
to be particularly helpful.
What I find-- and I'll
give you an example.
For instance, let's
say you're running.
You don't want to increase
your mileage more than 10%
in a week.
Or you don't want
to increase, maybe,
the length of a long run.
Or maybe before a triathlon--
not a triathlon, a longer
distance, like a marathon,
you start to taper.
So there's these
really nice easy rules
of thumb that could help
guide the ramping up
and the ramping down of the
volume of your training.
I love those rules.
They're so simple to apply.
But we don't really have those
rules of restraint in business.
Now, don't get me
wrong, business
is full of rules of
restraint, right?
There are things
like don't divulge
confidential information.
Don't give anyone your password.
Don't give information
in a negotiation.
Don't have an
inappropriate relationship
with your subordinates.
They keep us from doing bad
things, which is a good thing.
But they don't show
us how to grow.
They don't show us how
we can push our capacity
for growth, and at the same
time, perform as a business.
I want to share with you three
rules of intelligent restraint
that I think are fabulous
and easy to apply.
And my hope for you is
that, tomorrow, you'll
start thinking about,
well, how can I
put these to work for myself?
Now, there's three.
The first is focus
overrules vision.
The second, teams
beat strengths.
And the third is
exert, then recover.
And what I'd like to do is
spend the rest of my time
with you talking through
those three rules.
Let me focus on the first
one, focus overrules vision.
Now, before I
moved to Singapore,
I lived in Dallas, Texas.
And in December,
sometime in the '90s,
I can remember going to
see the Dallas marathon.
And James and I-- my husband--
he and I went to see
it with our friends.
And Harry and I stood at
the end, at the finish line.
Meanwhile, James and Christine
sat inside a nice warm cafe
nearby and ate pancakes.
Well, Harry and I were
so excited at the end,
watching and cheering people on.
Men, and women, and young
people and old people,
and fat people and
skinny people--
everyone was crossing
the finish line.
And we were so excited.
At one point, an athlete with
one leg and with crutches
crossed the finish line.
We were so inspired.
Harry and I looked at
each other so excited
because that man inspired us.
And we looked at each other
and, with complete earnestness,
we shook hands and said we're
going to run a marathon.
Well, the years went
by and the vision
faded, as did the passion.
Life intervened and it never
brought us to the marathon.
What brought me to the marathon,
eventually, wasn't the vision.
It was focus.
Now, my first marathon--
I had the holy focus of hope.
I mean, who wouldn't?
But after that, actually,
what drove me, the focus,
was actually a lot simpler.
I simply knew what the
next race would be.
Once I knew what the
next race would be,
I could have goals for
that race and say, well,
what is it actually
that I want to do?
And then I'd say, now, what's
it going to take to succeed?
Those three things
helped me get focus.
Once I had focus, I
could line up my life.
I could allocate
time and resources.
Since I'm a busy person--
I got a family, I work, I do
all of this stuff on the side--
I'd have to say no
to certain things.
And I'd have to line up
resources that would allow me
to allocate the time to train.
Because you can't really
cheat races like that.
You can cheat a half marathon.
You can't cheat 100k.
And so you really
have to change things.
You have to create routines.
So once I had the focus, I was
able to create a discipline
that allowed me to finish.
What I see often
in the work that we
do in organizations
is sometimes,
there's a fuzzy vision.
And sometimes, there's a bit
of a vision of growth, which
usually translates to
something like, we're
going to double our
sales at three years
or we want x percent improvement
in EBITDA over the next three
years.
So often, we just have
a numerical target.
What I see is that so many
leaders understand the race
they're in today,
but they don't know
what that next race will be.
If we don't know
that next race, we
can't know what success looks
like when we achieve it,
and we can't decide
what it takes to win.
The leaders who really get it
right, that's what they do.
They create incredible focus.
Not only focus for themselves,
but focus with others
in the organization.
They build a critical mass
that understands that.
And then they work very hard
to line up the resources needed
in order to win.
I will say that in the work
that we do with growth leaders,
we sometimes find that
they're not very popular.
Because sometimes
it's easy to say yes.
It's hard to say no.
It's easy to take resources.
It's hard to give them up.
So it's very challenging
for growth leaders
to not only create
focus, but also
to create real
alignment that means
that we allocate resources
to what really matters.
So I leave you with a thought
that while vision can get you
to the race, it's actually
focus that gets you
across the finish line.
Now, second rule is
routines beat strengths.
Now, when I first
started running,
I fell in love with it.
I think it was because
I read this great book.
It was called Running
the Spiritual Path.
And it basically taught me about
how to do running meditation.
And I would go out--
nothing made me happier
than to go out at about 6:00
in the morning and
run on trails all day.
This didn't make my family
very happy, by the way.
But to be breathing, and
meditating, and running,
I just absolutely loved it.
Now, I was pretty slow,
but that didn't bother me
because I knew in my heart
that this was my strength.
In fact, I even read books
that ridiculed people like me.
And they called it LSD,
Long Slow Distance.
And I said, that doesn't matter.
I'm a donkey.
That's what I'd say.
Not an ass, a donkey.
And so it served me well.
I could run very
far, very slowly.
But one day, at the end of a
40k run, I was coming back.
I was in the jungle.
And it was in a
very narrow trail.
And there was this
very large male monkey
sitting in front of me.
Now, I was a little
smelly at this point
because I had been running for
a really long time with a camel
pack and lots of food in it.
And I must have smelled
like eau de banana.
And as I came up to
that monkey, he shrieked
and he came towards me.
And I shrieked and I ran
in the other direction.
I took off like a gazelle.
As I sprinted, I felt
the dagger of his teeth
into the back of my calf.
I screeched.
I looked back.
There was no monkey.
In my haste to escape, in
my sprint of a gazelle,
I tore my calf.
I learned a very
important lesson.
You can't run like
a gazelle when
you've trained like a donkey.
[LAUGHTER]
I thought I had this strength.
It turned out not
to be a strength.
And what I learned is that
my strength, it limited me.
But we're the same way.
Think of how many
organizations--
we limit ourselves from
changing because we
want to rely on who we are
and what's made us successful.
When I changed tack, I
recovered from my torn calf,
I decided I wanted
a new challenge.
I would do triathlons.
That was much easier on my body.
And so I decided to
do a half Ironman.
So since I didn't
know what to do,
I hired a sports coach, which
I'm very thankful I did.
And I worked with a man named
Scott Molina, who himself is
an Ironman athlete and a coach.
And he worked with
me and I learned
something that was profound.
And it was that if I wanted to
improve the capacity of my body
to go further and faster,
what I needed to do
was implement progressively
challenging routines.
Our bodies are smart.
Like any system, if we don't
push them, they stay the same.
In fact, even going out and
having a really tough workout
doesn't make any difference.
It just keeps coming back.
It's one of the reasons
why you should never
restrict your calories too much
because your body doesn't just
lose weight.
It says, oh no, you're
starving, and it suddenly
becomes very efficient.
Our bodies are very smart.
What I learned from these
progressively challenging
routines was that
it was the routine
and the ongoing
challenge that sparked
the development of my capacity.
I think this is
really important.
There's an awful lot of
people in this room that are
in fields of human development.
And we've known for two
decades that experience
is a great teacher.
And we know that challenge
in experience develops.
But I want you just to go
away and think about that.
It's not just challenge.
It's progressively
challenging routines.
That changes systems.
That's what changes us.
It's not just a
random challenge.
Now, I want to give you an
example of an organization
that I think did a great job
with introducing a routine,
just to make this practical.
This is a company--
I'll call it ArtCo.
It's a marketplace
or platform for arts
and designed products for homes.
And ArtCo has been
very successful.
And it was growing so
fast that-- when you're
in a very high
growth environment,
it's very challenging
because you start your job
and, suddenly, it's changing.
So you have to be
changing very fast.
And the volume of work
is constantly changing.
There's a lot of newness,
a lot of challenge.
And one of the things that ArtCo
decided that they wanted to do
was to find a way to
help themselves scale.
So they introduced a routine
they call scaling day.
And as it sounds, scaling
day happened once a month.
And it started-- they'd
pick a little problem.
They would pick processes
or work activities
that they knew needed to scale,
in order to sustain growth.
And they had this
fabulous office.
In the middle, they
have a glass room.
Many of us have been
involved in activities
of documenting processes.
And usually, we sit
around and we have Word
documents and Google documents.
And we're documenting
lots of details
and no one cares about what
we write and no one ever
looks at it.
But what ArtCo did was they
made it part of their culture.
Scaling day was
something that people
wanted to be a part
of because they
knew it was part of the future.
And so people volunteered.
They gave their time.
They used it to be able
to scale for growth.
Now, in my book,
Pacing for Growth,
which I'm so excited
for you all to read,
you'll find a lot of
examples of routines
that you can use and implement
to build organization, team,
leader capabilities that
you need for the future.
The beauty of a routine
is that the right routine
helps you build the capabilities
that you need for the future
and it also helps
you conserve energy.
Now, let me talk
about the last one.
Exert and then recover.
It's a little bit different.
And I have to start with my
own reflection a very important
recovery moment.
In that first half
Ironman that I did--
that was the hardest
race I'd ever done.
It took me over seven hours.
And I came back.
I was so tired.
I remember my husband
and girls, they kind of
scraped me off the floor
and they put me in the car
and they took me home.
James, in the most
loving way, had
filled the bathtub full of ice.
He's just a man
after my own heart,
which is what I would do
after a really long run
because it would lower
my body temperature
and reduce inflammation.
My daughters were so sweet.
They created a
little spa for me.
And I believe that they
were giving me massages.
But I fell asleep so
quickly I don't even
remember what happened.
I woke up, consumed massive
amounts of carbohydrates,
fell asleep, and felt
much better the next day.
Now, that's recovery.
Actually, that's
called passive recovery
because passive
recovery is when we rest
and we recharge our battery.
And we all need that, right?
I think that's why
a lot of us are
happy that Friday is tomorrow.
So passive recovery
is really important.
It allows us to recharge.
But there's another
kind of a recovery
that's equally important.
And that's called
active recovery.
And at work, we tend to
think, well, I'm working
or I'm not working.
And with active
recovery, what we'll do
is we have a recovery
workout where we go slower.
Heart rate is slower.
It's easier on our body.
And it not only
helps us recover,
but it helps condition.
And it helps teach
our body how to exert.
And that's an important
aspect of the relationship
between exertion and recovery
It's kind of funny.
It's not the exertion
that helps us improve.
It's actually the
recovery, which I always
find so interesting.
I remember, I think
Troy told me a story.
Troy will be on our panel.
He said that when the
players are playing the game,
it's too late to coach.
And so one of the things
that we have to do
is to learn how to exert with
the right level of exertion,
and then to properly recover--
because those two
go hand-in-hand.
One of the things about
exertion is that often, we
just mindlessly exert.
We're like hamsters in a cage
and we're addicted to action.
We're just doing, doing, doing.
And we're not
thinking about, what's
the purpose of my exertion?
In training, we'll
have really high levels
where we're going all
out, just pushing up
the capacity of our heart.
Sometimes, we do race pace.
And race pace is helpful.
It helps us know what
it feels like when
we're going to be in the race.
There's other times where it's
just a little bit lower, where
we're really pushing
our aerobic capacity
and we're building our strength.
And then we have our
recovery workouts.
So part of what we have
to do as leaders is
learn to exert on what matters
and at the right level.
And we need to learn to balance
the right kind of recovery
with that.
What I see with the
leaders that I work with--
leaders of growth face constant
pressure because, on one hand,
we want to build
capabilities for the future.
At the same time, we have
to execute today's business.
And if we can't execute today's
business, if we can't perform,
there will be no future.
So really, we have to do both.
We have to perform
today and we have
to transform for the future.
And we have to learn how to do
these things without killing
people.
So this rule of thumb is a
way of us thinking about,
how do we exert mindfully
on what most matters?
How do we create routines
that allow us to do that?
How do we allow ourselves
to recover in the right way
that both teaches us how to
exert, as well as to recover?
Now, what I'd like
to do is wrap up.
And I'd like to say thank
you to Google because you all
have a fabulous facility here.
And it's so cool.
One of the things that my team
really appreciated working here
was just to see how Google
not only created this world
class, dynamic, and
collaborative work space,
but also spent energy
teaching their employees how
to manage their own energy
using the workplace.
And so I think you're
really a role model of that.
And I want to
encourage all of you
to think about that,
about how do you help
people manage their own energy?
I want to thank all
of you for being here
and listening to my
story and participating.
We're only halfway done.
We're going to do a TV talk show
inspired by Graham Norton soon.
I hope that I managed to
get you excited and curious
about intelligent restraint.
I hope that you'll leave
here today thinking
about how you can apply these
principles or these rules
of intelligent restraint and
become endurance athletes
for business growth.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Now, what I'd like to
do is, in the moments
that Darryl's going to
come up onto the stage,
I want you to look to your
left and to your right
and I want you to introduce
yourself to the person sitting
next to you.
There's no strangers here.
And when Daryl comes
up, then we'll begin.
It's my pleasure to
introduce Darryl Dickens,
the host of our fabulous show.
Darryl.
[APPLAUSE]
DARRYL DICKENS: I'm mic'd up.
So it's amazing when you
know somebody for 20 years
and then you learn
something completely new.
That's just really
inspirational.
Fantastic.
And now, ladies and
gentlemen, comes
the next part of the evening.
And we have an
outstanding panel.
Absolutely outstanding.
I'm going to start
to bring them up.
And I want lots of energy,
lots and lots of energy
as they come up.
Now, the first person is
literally a rock star.
Not figuratively.
He actually plays in
a rock and roll band.
He's CEO of [INAUDIBLE].
Come on up, Richard.
[APPLAUSE]
All right.
Look at that.
Now the next person is
former Olympic coach
who has recently
moved to Singapore
and has a fascinating
role here now
as head of coach development
for Sport Singapore, Mr. Troy
Engle, sprint on up.
[APPLAUSE]
Thanks, coach.
Now next, we have somebody
who I just met last week.
And I have to say,
this person has
one of the sunniest dispositions
that I've ever encountered.
Elizabeth, better known
as Lizzy [? Hamrun, ?]
who is VP and head of HR.
Come on up.
Bring some of that
glow to the panel.
Fantastic.
Now, last but not
least, somebody
who is head of a incredible
high growth part of the Google
business, head of
YouTube, which I probably
watch 20 minutes a day, and
less and less cat videos,
actually, which is
quite encouraging.
A little more content, now.
I'm going to introduce
Ajay Vidyasagar.
Come on up.
Let's make some more content.
Because we just don't
have enough content.
Let's film this and
make some more content.
All right.
Now, look at that.
We're all lined up.
We're all ready.
I'm excited.
I feel like we're poised
like a [INAUDIBLE]
for a fantastic panel.
Now, I was thinking how
should we kick things off?
And I just think that
it's a very natural segue
from the author to actually
the CEO of a very significant
company that you
have built. And I
think people want to hear how
do you drink your own Merlot.
Actually, you like to
drink sauvignon blanc.
So how do you drink your
own sauvignon blanc?
And when have you found
that, at the company,
you're running the wrong race?
That you had to change
the pace, slower, faster?
How did you know
and what did you do?
ALISON EYRING: I'll
answer the first one
because I do prefer
sauvignon blanc over Merlot.
It will be served later.
So we're a relatively
small firm.
We have about 50 people.
And one of the
things that we do,
because part of Pacing
for Growth is about,
how do you drive execution
in the day-to-day business,
as well as build
capabilities for the future?
And one of the
things that we do is
we look at work that we have
to do that's particularly
challenging that we
can create and that we
can structure so
that it's a learning
experience for our team.
And then we use a
structured process
to help them accelerate their
development as they're also
delivering work.
So that would be an
example of what we do.
DARRYL DICKENS: So it's--
go ahead.
SPEAKER 1: I was
going to tell a story
about where I've seen really
poor intelligent restraint.
We were talking
about this earlier.
I used to work, I feel
like it's a confession.
I used to work in
investment banking.
I'm very sorry.
You can love me anyway.
[INAUDIBLE]
Yeah.
And I worked for a company
where, pre the crash,
where exertion became a
byword for being employable.
And there was this
confluence of always
on technology, the
explosion in capital markets
and global markets.
And this really,
really alpha culture.
And I kid you not, the group HR
director took a conference call
in the middle of
the London Marathon
as a sign of commitment.
And you have this
amazing situation
where league tables
were going around
about who stayed in the office
the latest-- as a good thing,
by the way, as a good thing--
answering the call at 3:00 AM.
And what we found, by doing
some research, was that--
we used to use these
algorithms that
checked for insider dealing.
I can tell you some more
over a glass of wine.
The behavior patterns
that people exhibited
when they were getting
ready to do insider dealing
were the same behavior patterns
that people displayed when
they were behaving unethically.
And then, because we had all
these league tables about who
was working, we had
all the technology
to read who was working,
we did an overlay.
Guess who were the people
who were displaying the worst
ethical behaviors?
It's the people who were tired.
So the people who'd
been overworking.
And we found, this
blew my mind and it'll
blow yours, tired people
make worse ethical decisions
than drunk people.
Now, go figure.
And then you look at this
always on alpha culture
and how many companies
now don't own any assets.
They just own their
reputation and their brand.
And then you look at
how many organizations
have suffered ethical crises.
Enron, WorldCom, [? Andisor, ?]
The list goes on.
And so exert and then
recover, I think,
is a massive gap, actually, in
the way that people work today
and it's had really
dire consequences.
So it's something that I think
we should really watch out for.
And I know I've just seen the
worst examples of that ever,
really.
DARRYL DICKENS: It's
interesting, too,
because you were talking a
little bit about the business
cycles and the
additional pressures.
Richard, you have such an
amazing set of retail outlets.
You have sourcing.
You have a very significant
complex organization.
You're expanding to the north.
And you've seen some
different business cycles.
I'd be fascinated to hear,
whether it was a growth cycle
that you really wanted to
ride out and really scale
or whether it was a downturn.
What examples have
you seen where
you had to really change
the pace of the company
to weather it?
SPEAKER 2: The problem
is we can never
see what's happening outside.
And we know what's going
on within the organization.
But external factors can
throw everything off.
In 1997, end of '96, we had
just completed one buyout
and we were preparing
to continue expansion.
And what happens is the
Asian financial crisis.
And we were in a meeting.
I was in a meeting
in [INAUDIBLE].
I remember this internal
manager meeting.
We were talking how to
expand everything else
with our financial partners.
And then the message comes
in overnight, interest rates
have hit--
I don't know, whatever
percent it was--
10s of percents.
And we have a lot of debt.
So you wonder, what the hell
is going to go wrong next?
So your plans, no matter
how good they are,
are subject to these
outside influences.
And you have to
modify all the time.
ALISON EYRING: I heard
this great quote once.
It said that we
always overestimate
the impact of what we've been--
the 10-year trends-- and
then we underestimate
what happens next month.
SPEAKER 2: Yeah.
ALISON EYRING: But
it's interesting
because I think that
one of the concepts
of intelligent restraint
is around building two
important growth capabilities.
One is of outside-in
thinking and the other
is around customer
aligned innovation.
And those are really
muscles that we
have to exercise more and more
because you're exactly right.
You could not have known.
But you could be very
fast and responsive.
So it's about understanding that
there's these little unknowns.
You have to be very adaptable.
And then there's other unknowns.
But we know they're
happening, but then we're
not being proactive enough to--
SPEAKER 2: So in
terms of growth,
you have to pace yourself.
But actually, what happened was,
every time there was a crisis,
we tried to expand because that
was actually the best time.
Because we're retailers
and when there's
a recession or whatever,
rental prices go down.
So actually, that's the
best time to pick up leases
and so on.
But we grew a lot that way
through the financial crisis,
[INAUDIBLE] and all
that sort of thing.
But the other thing
is about this routine.
So actually it's a lot
about training and getting
the team ready so
that you have to--
when we open branches,
there are people
who can just go in and
operate straight away.
And we don't try to open a
branch and then hire people.
You actually got to
hire people first.
DARRYL DICKENS: And
that's very interesting.
It goes back to the comment
that Troy made around,
once you're on the
field, you can't really
expect to have
any more coaching.
You've really got to be
able to adapt, real time,
and run whatever plays
you have to now do.
So when we think about the,
again, the fascinating analogy
around, and learnings from,
the endurance training,
what else should we think
about and take away,
Troy, in terms of building
high performance teams,
breaking barriers, but
doing it with the right kind
of intelligent restraint?
What have you seen, in terms
of the actual exporting side?
TROY ENGLE: I think
that, as I told Alison
in my first conversation
with her, the kind of things
that we talked about, and
then when I read the book.
This book literally
could be a book
about distance running
or endurance running,
and that's my background.
It's all about not just the
rules of endurance training
that Alison mentioned.
There are certain
percentages of growth.
They're really more
principles of training
that are based on physiological
response, and as I read this,
I realized are adaptable to the
physiology of an organism, too.
Things like what
we used to call--
we talk about the principle
of specificity of training.
You have to understand
what the specific demands
of the athletic performance
are and you train for those.
You focus on the 97%,
rather than the 3%.
We talk about the principles
of load and recovery
because the adaptation
actually happens in that time
away from the exertion when
the body reflects and adapts.
Principles of progressive
overload, that you constantly
stress the system.
Because from a
coaching standpoint,
all the advances
happen at the margin.
They don't happen
through under-training.
And they absolutely don't
happen through overtraining.
And in the endurance world, as
Alison and I have talked about,
there are three or four
different critical margins.
There's submaximal margins.
There's margins that
we talk about called
the anaerobic threshold, which
is that level that you can
basically maintain for an
extended period of time
without accumulating fatigue.
That's a really
critical threshold.
It's highly trainable.
You go beyond, you
stress the system where
there's a risk of breakdown.
And then there are super maximal
thresholds, which you probably
need, at times, to bump to
so you can expect that pace.
You can train for those
changes in the market, changes
in the pace.
But you know you can't
sustain them for long,
so you throttle back
down and regroup.
So I'm reading this going,
geez, this book is--
number one, it makes
me feel smart because I
see my track coaching could
actually, probably, be
more than just with what we do.
But it works for everybody.
It's not principles
that are only
applied at the Olympic level.
They're also with-- they're
responses throughout all
of endurance training.
ALISON EYRING: One thing
I was going to add--
often, organizations really
struggle to think about,
what is their maximum capacity?
We understand today.
But it's hard to
imagine, how are we
going to be changed tomorrow?
And one of the stories I told in
the book that I loved was about
how all the experts used to say
the four-minute mile cannot be
broken.
Right?
It was just not going to happen.
And it took a young
doctor in the UK
who trained for three
months and then broke it.
And then the record's been
broken 17 times since.
And so I think that
we see that in sport.
That we often have
that idea about, well,
what's the best I can be?
But then in fact, it's not true.
TROY ENGLE: There have been--
Roger Bannister broke
the four minute mile.
And they said it
could never be broken.
And there have now
been over 400 people.
So we just recalibrate.
And the earlier point
about ethical decisions.
I think, clearly
within our world,
ethics is a huge issue in sport.
Drugs in sport are
a major problem.
The thing that most
people don't realize
is that the most common drugs--
they don't make you faster.
What they allow you
to do is work more.
They reinforce that thought
that more is always better.
But the reality is it's
not no pain no gain.
It's no brain, lots
of pain, or something.
You really have to figure out
what the capacity is and it's
there for a reason.
DARRYL DICKENS: On
maximum capacity,
when I think about
a business, I think
about YouTube and the phenomenal
growth-- it's hyper growth.
So when you're talking
about maximum capacity,
how do you, Ajay, look at
removing constraints just
to continue that
maximum capacity
to take up the opportunity.
AJAY VIDYASAGAR:
Actually, I think
I want to share something
that really shook me
up when I [INAUDIBLE].
I had this very flourishing
career in television.
And I said, this is a
place that operates a lot
like [INAUDIBLE] in television.
And within a few months
after I came to YouTube,
which was a rocket ship.
It was going really well.
There was something
that happened
that really made me very,
very nervous about what
we were doing.
At that time, around
85% of our consumption
happened from desktops.
And about 15% of our consumption
happened from mobile devices.
So I vividly remember this
day when we were all called
in for a leadership meeting.
We were told, long story
short, that any content that
comes in to this platform
that does not make itself
available on a mobile
device will not
be [INAUDIBLE] on YouTube.
And [INAUDIBLE] these
guys should be nuts.
We have such an extraordinary
amount of volume of desktops.
DARRYL DICKENS: We're
doing so well already.
Why change it?
AJAY VIDYASAGAR: I was
sitting there saying,
man, I gave up an
amazing career.
What have I got into?
So every day now,
when I think about it,
it was a lot of what you
talk about in this book.
It is really about prioritizing
and focusing and having
a very vivid vision of what the
world is going to be and not
really--
restrain yourself
[? bases ?] the local data
that you're operating within.
Today, in many markets, we
have almost the flip of what we
we at seven years back.
We have 6 to 7 out
of 10 minutes being
consumed on connected
smartphone devices.
And pretty much, every
large video platform
in the world today
struggles with a situation
where consumers don't get
a consistent experience
on all devices, which
is fundamentally what
we re-engineered at that time.
And I think it's a great
example of actually
having a pretty clear vision
of what you want to be
and focusing on
just that one thing.
And sacrificing an entire
bunch of things that
may look very painful then.
But you're going to have an
entire [? division group ?]
[INAUDIBLE].
ALISON EYRING: It's also a great
example of how constraints--
actually deliberately
constraining certain things
helps create clarity.
DARRYL DICKENS: We're having
a fantastic panel here.
I just want to pause to see,
are there any questions?
I was talking to some folks.
Some folks said they had
some doozy questions for us.
Any questions from the audience?
It's a great opportunity.
ALISON EYRING: Or
shouts of joy, comments?
DARRYL DICKENS: Exactly.
No takers?
OK.
All right.
When I think about the
book, the three big things
we should remember
to take away-- this
shows that I was paying
attention, Alison.
But I, again, ask the panel.
We all have very
different mandates,
in terms of what we work in.
But if we think that
focus overrules vision
and that routines
beat strengths.
And that you exert,
but must recover.
We're not saying you don't
want to do all three,
but given the circumstances that
you face with your very, very
different businesses, which one
would you prioritize right now
and why?
SPEAKER 1: I'll have
a go at that one.
Years ago, I never
thought I'd give
this answer which is I think
routines beat strengths.
ALISON EYRING: Yes.
SPEAKER 1: I spent 10
years in an alpha business
and being taught that all you
need to focus on is strengths.
And if you find somebody who's
working for Google or Apple,
you ask them one question
in the interview, which
is, when can you start?
And you focus on your
superstars and your top 10%.
And you ignore the ecosystem.
And I just think that's
absolutely bullshit.
And I've learned, no offense
to the talent at Google,
obviously.
[LAUGHTER]
I'm in the wrong room.
No.
The ecosystem that the
majority of your people
experience every day is
the thing to go after.
It's not the hypo 10%.
It's not simply the
new product generation.
It's, what's the
majority experience
that everyone's leaning into
and experiencing every day?
Because that's what
touches your customer.
And you can't get to
every individual employee.
But you can architect the
environment that they're in.
And so routines beats strengths
is definitely one for us.
And Alison is working with us
on this super cool piece of work
at the moment where
we are crowdsourcing,
from our front line employees,
to author our new culture
because we want to put
more speed and energy
into our organization.
We're an amazing organization
with a huge deep sense
of purpose.
But we say things like, if you
could go and change the world
and just get through
these 10 committees first.
That would be wonderful
if you could get consensus
around that human organ you're
growing, that would be amazing.
What?
How does that square?
And so Alison's
helping us unleash
the energy in the
organization by creating
new routines for everybody
to get to that majority
experience.
And that's what I've learned.
That's been a big learning for
me over the last few years.
DARRYL DICKENS: It's amazing.
I have spent-- I don't know--
everybody must be in
the same situation.
I have spent work weeks
doing know your strengths,
the management offside.
And oh, you're a yellow.
Oh, you're a green.
Oh, well, you work very--
on and on.
And then I read the book.
And I go, well, it's
the routine that you
are really clear about that's
going to get you there.
And I found that one
a big one, as well.
Because I was just
thinking, ugh, all that
stuff I went through.
ALISON EYRING: Well, I think
one of my favorite chapters
was the scale to grow,
which was really about,
how do you have an
abundance mindset?
And I think, when you
have an abundance mindset,
you don't say, oh, it's
just one or two people
that are the chosen ones.
You say, well,
actually, if we're
going to execute today's
business and make it better
and we're going to build
capabilities for the future,
we need a lot of
people on that journey.
And those people have
to be growing faster.
And it can't just be this slow--
oh, let's go send them all to
this really expensive program.
It's got to be anytime,
anywhere, anyhow.
And I think that's
a mindset that we
have to shift that we can
develop people better,
faster, and cheaper when
we change the way we think
about how we develop them.
DARRYL DICKENS:
Other comments, team,
in terms of the three rules.
Which one do--
SPEAKER 2: I think if you're
building the organization
and getting everybody into
doing the right thing,
then routines is
the most important.
But I think at the
leadership level,
I think you have to think
about focus, as well.
But you're never going to--
I'm not going to-- frankly,
a shop assistant isn't
going to think too
much about, what's
the focus for the group today?
But at the leadership level,
you've got to do that.
But on the other hand,
routine is something
that everybody in the
organization can do.
ALISON EYRING: I
totally agree with you.
And I think about that
in my own business.
It's so easy for us to
know what today's race is.
What are the capabilities
for the next one?
That's really much harder.
TROY ENGLE: I'll
take a different one.
From a coaching perspective, I
think that focus trumps vision.
From a coaching perspective,
particularly when
you've identified what
your current capacity is.
We have an old coaching
expression that hope
really isn't a strategy.
And so I think our motto is
design the plan, work the plan,
and trust the plan.
And I think if you start
with a sense of what
your current
capacity is and it's
based on where you need to be--
and in our case, in
endurance training,
it may be scientific based--
you've got your focus.
It's very focused.
You don't get distracted
of off what else.
You know your current fitness.
You know your desired fitness.
You're going to figure
out the plan to get there.
And there's a great coach--
obviously, I'm an American--
who orchestrated an amazing--
yeah, at this point in time,
I'm taking no sympathy.
[LAUGHTER]
DARRYL DICKENS: Well, at least
you're here and not there.
TROY ENGLE: But anyway, we came
off a great American sporting
event.
110 million people
watched the Super Bowl,
greatest comeback in history.
And it was orchestrated
by one of the greatest
sports coaches ever, a
guy named Bill Belichick.
And his motto with his
team is do your job.
Do your job.
And somebody asked what
the halftime speech
was that resulted in
a 25-point turnaround.
And the speech was, do your job.
You all know where we are.
You know what you've got to do.
Do your job.
So I think--
DARRYL DICKENS: Brady
[? had ?] at [? 6'3''. ?]
TROY ENGLE: I don't know.
His wife tells me
he should retire.
So I don't know.
[INAUDIBLE]
ALISON EYRING: I had this
one story in the book
about a leader who's running a
very high growth organization.
And one of my favorite
quotes from him was--
I said, what's your secret?
And he says, I do my job and
I let my people do theirs.
DARRYL DICKENS: Ajay,
you want to choose
one that, right now, fits what
with the mandate is at YouTube?
AJAY VIDYASAGAR: I'll echo what
I said earlier, which is really
around having a very
well defined focus
and having an entire battery
of people buy into the vision.
Doing that is not easy.
At any point of
time, in any market,
you have so many opportunities
and so many problems.
And to try and bottle
all of it up into one
overarching them and
then getting people
to run the same race in the same
direction and at the same pace
is tough to do.
But when you pull it off,
and when it starts humming,
it's a joy to be a part of.
SPEAKER 1: Alison,
can I just tell you,
you caused marital
disharmony in my home.
Because my husband--
I gave him the book because
I thought it was brilliant.
He also is a long
distance runner.
And I say, it's
really great and you
can apply it and everything.
And he said, oh yeah,
great, great, great.
And he came running in
about an hour later.
And said, see?
See?
I've been telling
you this for years.
And I said, what do you mean?
What are you talking about?
He said, when I'm lying there
and you say, what are you doing
and I say, nothing.
And you say, well, you look
like you need some jobs to do,
I'm recovering after exerting.
[LAUGHTER]
Nothing is a thing.
I am recovering.
So you owe me a glass of wine.
AJAY VIDYASAGAR: He should
have been on the panel today.
SPEAKER 2: So 90%
recovery and 10% exertion.
[LAUGHTER]
DARRYL DICKENS: I think somebody
mentioned wine didn't they?
Did they mention wine?
I'm thinking I'm not going to
show any intelligent restraint
whatsoever over cocktails.
None whatsoever.
I think we're getting
up to about where we're
supposed to get to, right?
I'd like to thank the panel.
It's been an outstanding
conversation.
Alison, congratulations
on the book.
It was heartfelt and memorable.
And it's an
outstanding audience.
I'm really looking forward
to network with folks here
and have a little bit of wine.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]